pleased to welcome back to the Rich
Eisen show Troy Aikman how are you Troy
may be rimmed hun good thank you I'm
thrilled to have you here so the Chris
Borland retirement how did how did that
sit with you Troy uh you know I really
didn't know what to make up um you know
knowing exactly what his history had
been I know he was terrific last year
was impressive coming into the league
and then got his opportunity to play and
did an excellent job it sounded like I
heard last night that he had actually
considered not even starting his NFL
career that he had thought about given
up football you know following college
so you know how much of this is really
related to head injuries and his concern
there how much of it is related to you
know him just wanting to maybe get on
with other parts of his life I really
don't know I've not met Chris but I know
it's always hard to make that decision
if you are in love with game and giving
something up that you've been doing for
a really long time and and looking far
enough ahead to your future is something
that very few guys are capable of doing
her are able to do so from that
standpoint I applaud them Troy Aikman
Fox Sports joining me here on the
program well you know you know you're
part of the paparazzi now in the media
or at least you know you're you're in
television let's put it that way we in
the paparazzi talking about this every
single day are looking for a greater
meaning here Troy that this is either a
sign that the NFL will have an issue
keeping young players to play the game
or getting young players to play the
game do you see this potentially as that
Troy um well I think that you know what
I've heard in a recent report is that
concussions are down across the board in
our sport which is very positive news I
don't you know when the last time that
you know there I don't know when the
last time there was a decrease in head
injuries so I think maybe some of the
steps that are being taken not only at
the NFL level but at all levels is
paying dividends whether or not you know
that ultimately is enough to sway my
than dad in letting their young boys
play the sport I don't know numbers are
down in terms of uh participation at the
grassroots level and I think that's the
biggest concern for all of us is what
does the sport look like you know 10 15
20 years from now is participation
continues to decline at the rate that it
has you know anytime there is a player
and not even necessarily a prominent
player you know regards to Chris Borland
it certainly brings up a lot of
attention to dangers in the list of our
sport nothing new but I think the game
is certainly safer than it's ever been
but i think that the reports have come
out whatever long-term possible effects
a player could have from the credit of
head injury uh is certainly a concern
and i think it's going to take some time
uh you know to continue to study it see
what's happening with a number of
players and then with the changes that
have been made that been made so
recently just in the last you know few
years what does that look like more
importantly as we look at players who
have played under these existing rules
you know for the next kind of 15 years
well it just seemed that the risk that's
assumed by players to to lace them up at
any level obviously but certainly at the
national football league level troy it
seemed that the risk that a player
assumes was at the top of chris borland
mind and i'm wondering does an NFL
player just ignore that risk when you're
playing do you put it aside and then
revisit it later on what were you like
when you played in regards to having the
risk be at a conscious level for you
yeah they're there was no real
information for me to look at you know
there was no no there was no
determination at that time but that head
injury created any long-term effects you
know I was never advised by a doctor
that I should do at the game but I think
we all recognize that what you know
whether it's broken bones you know torn
up knees whatever it might be with
regards to those types of injuries we
knew we all know
and they all know now that there's a
price to pay and I think that you know
all of the sudden okay well you know hey
if if going out and getting a chance to
do something that you really love if
that means that you're not going to walk
particularly well when you're in your
50s or 60s but i think you know most
players were alone to accept those
wrists and you say hey that's just a
part of it but when you start talking
about the quality of life with regards
to you know are you able to remember
things you know are you able to function
mentally i think that's entirely
different and so these players now they
have a lot more information for them to
dissect and determine whether or not the
wrists are worth of the war what about
you do you wake up sometimes feel
something that you think might be
related to your playing days how about
you Troy Aikman you know I really don't
rich I i I've always said I've been real
fortunate I I certainly am aware of some
former players and former teammates even
that have had some issues because of the
concussions and head injuries that they
suffered there's a place here in Dallas
called brain health but I went last year
and I went through a series of tests and
not that I had had anything that
concerned me but I just thought hey it's
right here in my backyard i'll speak
kind of where I'm at and it took a
couple weeks for them to pull all the
information together after i texted and
when i went back they they were quite
impressed surprisingly i guess they said
that I tested uh you know amongst some
of the highest that have ever come
through so that made me feel good it was
certainly a guest a sense of relief um
but you know doing the job that I have
in broadcasting I think that keeps me
active mentally but I haven't had any
issues that have been caused for
concerned and and I hope that that
continues but I know some other players
have been less fortunate and even beyond
the head injuries that I had the only
significant injury that i really had
while i played was was a back injury
where i had surgery and that was
actually what would cause me to retire
it wasn't the head injuries it was my
back issues i was having to take shots
throughout my last season to get out
onto the field and try to play and even
that is healed up so i have no physical
ailments I'm very active and
and then not only I haven't noticed
anything either so I've been real quick
Troy Aikman joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show what did you make of the
DeMarco Murray sodding by the Eagles
Troy yeah I think what the Eagles have
done has been you know it's been real
interesting and watch you know I can
only imagine if you're an eagles fan and
seeing all that's gone on you know and
where they're going to be going into
next year I the DeMarco Murray signing
by the Eagles was outstanding my opinion
I'm a huge fan of DeMarco was prior to
last year he's got great toughness EP so
he's a serious guy you really uh places
extreme importance on the game of
football he wanted to stay in Dallas
rich uh and i think he was willing to
maybe take a little less money to stay
here and and but i think the guarantees
that the eagles offered and even a
couple of other teams for that matter
surpassed what Dallas was doing and I
think Alice decided that as much as
they'd like to keep the markle Murray I
know they wanted to keep them but they
had established a ceiling on a price and
once it got beyond that they were going
to stick to their plan and you know so
some have been critical of the Cowboys
for that men on the other hand some of
some of applauded before because they've
shown some constraint and it's something
that they've really not done a good job
of showing in previous years well yeah
well a lot of people are saying that
Steven's running the show there and is
there is a one that that is telling dad
you know maybe we should tighten the
belt here there and that's what's
happening there well i would i would say
that don't kid yourself Jerry's always
running the show master he's always a
master of ceremonies but I do think that
I do think that Steve and not and not
just this offseason I think it's done on
for the last you know three or four
years that that he has been able to
influence some of the things that have
been occurring and you know we all know
the Stevens going to be running this
team at some point in time and I think
he does have his hand in a lot of the
decisions that have been made Troy
before I let you go Sam Bradford now the
guy there in Philadelphia you'll be
calling a lot of eagles games I'm sure
in late windows on Fox based on you know
their popularity and how many moves have
been made so many people still can't
wrap
arms around the idea that Chip Kelly's
first hand-picked quarterback in his
two-plus seasons in Philadelphia is this
young man who has had injuries to his
knee the last two seasons how does he
fit in your concept with the chat the
chip kelly concept how does he work
there well it's it's really a matter of
you know whether or not he can stay
healthy I think he's agile enough to run
that offense you know what I saw Sam
coming out of college week we did not
have one rammstein uh since he joined
the team so I haven't even had a chance
to watch him play in person and of
course those that have had their games a
lot of times you have him down the field
but I'm I'm interested in seeing how he
does in this system I love the office I
really like Jeff Kelly system he's a
really bright guy he being Chip Kelly
and for him to have more say in the
personnel this offseason and make the
move that he's made including that trade
for Sam Bradford I make just to see how
they do and how these plays within this
system and I've got enough confidence in
chip that if he sees some things in Sam
that he really likes then I like to move
to until proven otherwise it's just a
matter of whether or not he can stay on
the field Troy thanks again for taking
the time man Rick I look forward to the
next time don't be a stranger okay Troy
oh all right my man okay thanks that's
Troy Aikman you bet that's Troy Aikman
to Fox Sports so rich eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience